Transcriber: Ivana Korom
Reviewer: Joanna Pietrulewicz
Like many people
who have been fortunate enough
to be more or less healthy,
I spent most of my life
never thinking much about my body.
Something that I relied on
to get me around,
not to mind the occasional bash
and not to complain too much
if I wasn't getting enough rest.
But that all changed for me
when I became pregnant.
Suddenly, my body was this machine
performing an incredible task.
That was something
that I had to take notice of
and look after,
so that it could do its job.
I've been a documentary photographer
for nearly 20 years now
but I never turned the camera
on myself until that time.
And then suddenly,
I found myself fascinated
by how we feel about our bodies
and how we express strength or fear,
courage or shyness
in the way we carry ourselves.
I spent several years making work
that examined the relationship
that we have to our bodies as humans.
More recently, though,
I've been exploring a new frontier
in the human body.
A transformation of bodies
with technology.
As humans evolve along with technology,
and the lines between the two
become increasingly blurred,
I set out to document our evolution
into a new kind of human
and to play with that age-old question:
Can we ever see a real
humanness in machines?
Sight is perhaps the most personal
and intimate of our senses.
Classically called the window to the soul.
We connect with each other,
recognize each other
and communicate with each other
through our eyes.
If we lose an eye,
we might wear a dummy replacement
so that our face resembles
what it did before.
Filmmaker Rob Spence
took that a step further
when he installed a video camera
in his replacement eye
so that he could record his vision.
Rob is part of a known network of cyborgs
and he told me that he found it curious
when he started to receive
hate mail from people
who felt threatened by him
having this extra ability.
Was his right to change his body
less important than their right
to their privacy?
So as I photographed Rob,
he filmed me using the camera in his eye,
and we recorded it on a special receiver.
But perhaps in response to the speed
with which we all move
and make images these days
I wanted to make this work
in a way that was slow and purposeful.
Most of these images are shot
on a large-format camera.
These are big and cumbersome,
taking only one frame at a time
before you have to change the film.
To check the focus,
you have to put your head
under a black cloth
and use a magnifying glass.
So as I photographed Rob
using this very old technology,
he filmed me using the camera in his eye,
somewhat the opposite end
of the technology spectrum.
But I wanted to delve deeper
and explore more of what it could mean
to lose a part of ourselves
and replace it with technology.
At MIT Media Lab
they are doing some of the most
cutting-edge work in biomechatronics,
developing motorized limbs for amputees.
Originally set up by Hugh Herr,
a double amputee who was able to develop
and test the equipment on himself.
He went on to create
a set of legs that can walk,
run and even jump
without seeming to be mechanical at all.
The gait more closely resembles
that of a human foot and leg
because the motor gives the wearer
a push off the floor
to move the foot forwards from the ankle.
The technology here,
continuing to be developed by Matt Carney
and his colleagues at MIT,
is really quite impressive,
with the prosthesis connecting directly
into the amputee's bone for stability,
and sensors reading pulses
from the amputee's muscles
to tell the limb how to move.
Ultimately, the wearer should be able
to think about moving their foot
and the foot would move.
They're impressive to look at
by themselves.
But of course, the prostheses
don't move on their own.
In order to show
their relationship to humans,
I wanted to show how they enable amputees
to move with ease and fluidity.
But how do you photograph gait?
At this point, I was inspired
by the work and photographs
of Eadweard Muybridge,
who is famous for his series of images
of a running horse, made in 1878,
to prove that there's a moment
when all four of the horse's feet
are off the ground at the same time.
He went on to make hundreds of series
of images of animals and humans in motion.
It was groundbreaking work
and gave us one of the first opportunities
to study the anatomy of motion.
So I wanted to try and create
similar kinds of motion studies
of amputees walking, running,
jumping, using this technology,
and to think of them as motion studies
of an enhanced human motion.
One of the things I learned at MIT
was the incredible importance of balance
and the complex system
of reactions and muscles
that enable us to stand on two feet.
Those of us with children
will remember with fond nostalgia
the moment our kids
take their first steps.
But what we think of as endearing
is actually an incredible feat
of balance and counterbalance.
It can be quite daunting.
This is my daughter Lorelei
standing for the first time
without any support.
It lasted only a few seconds.
Dance, in particular,
is all about balance and mastering
the fluidity of movement.
Pollyanna here lost her leg in an accident
when she was just two years old.
She's learned to dance
with the aid of a blade prosthesis
and she now competes in a class
alongside nonamputees.
But the skill of moving around on two legs
and navigating often uneven ground
is incredibly difficult to replicate.
Over at Munich's technical university
they've developed LOLA,
a biped humanoid robot
that can move on two legs
and make her way
around a series of obstacles.
As she strides along,
she looks powerful and impressive.
But her movement is also
somewhat clunky and mechanical
and not as spontaneous
or unpredictable as that of humans.
At the end of it all,
when she switched off,
she hung down on her cables
and looked kind of forlorn.
And in that moment,
I saw her as more human
than I had done
when she was walking along.
I felt almost sorry
that she had been switched off.
Her exterior might be cold and mechanical,
but when vulnerable,
she looked more real to me.
Alex Lewis is a quadruple amputee
who lost his limbs and part of his face
when he fell ill with strep A.
One of the most inspiring people
I have ever met.
His journey to recovery
has been an incredibly tough one.
He now has a chip in his arm
to open his front door,
a set of mechanical arms,
and a handcycle to get around.
Depending on what he is doing,
be it throwing a ball for the dog,
riding his handcycle, or even canoeing,
he has a different set of hands
that he attach to the end of his arms.
It's been a very tough journey,
but the hardships he's faced
have given Alex a superhuman ambition.
He genuinely told me
that his ordeal is the best thing
that ever happened to him.
He now goes on expeditions,
climbing mountains in Africa,
he's planning to cycle across Mongolia,
and he works with London’s
Imperial College,
helping to develop a motorized hand,
much like the legs
they are developing at MIT.
He may be less physically
able than before,
but understanding his weaknesses
has made Alex emotionally very strong
and opened up a world
of opportunity for him.
It made me realize
that our emotions and understanding
the limits of our physicality
are also a huge part
of what makes us strong.
In Osaka
I meet professor Ishiguro,
who makes robots with uncannily
human faces and expressions.
First, I meet Geminoid,
the robot he created in his own likeness.
On the grid here you can see
three pictures of the robot,
one of the professor.
Can you tell which is which?
One of his more recent creations is Ibuki,
a robot made to look
like a ten-year-old boy,
who can wave and show
a range of facial expressions.
In those expressions,
I saw a certain vulnerability
that made Ibuki feel very real to me.
When he was angry or sad, it resonated.
And when he smiled,
I wanted to smile back.
I feel I was drawn to Ibuki
as I might have been to a real child.
And at the end of it all,
I felt I wanted to thank him
or reach out and shake his hand.
So if understanding
the limits of our physicality
can help to make us stronger,
then seeing the vulnerability
in Ibuki's expressions
made him feel more human to me.
So where do we go from here?
In Tokyo, I meet professor Takeuchi
who's developed a form of synthetic muscle
that can respond to an electric pulse
and expand or contract
just like a real muscle.
As it does so, the little limb here
moves back and forth.
Now this sample is only tiny,
but imagine the possibilities
if synthetic limbs
could be made out of this.
And what if that could be combined
with the technology
that reads nerve pulses
from the end of an amputee's limb?
Perhaps it could respond to touch
and feel something hot or sharp,
sending a message back up to our brains,
just like it does in our body.
Understanding those vulnerabilities
would make the technology stronger too.
Throughout the course of making this work,
I've met some incredible people,
both using and creating technology.
I've seen crazy possibilities
for how we'll mend and enhance our bodies.
But I've also smiled at a robot,
seen a young girl
leap through the air on a blade
and shaken the hand of a man with no hands
who towers emotionally above us all.
I'm left in awe of the complexity
of the human body.
But I also feel
that it's not just our bodies,
bionics or not,
that make us strong,
but our emotions
and understanding our weaknesses.
But I'd like to think
of these works as studies,
something that we can come back to
and carefully observe.
A point in our evolution
before time runs away with us all.
Thank you.